in 2017 i was featured in which top 100
list jrm's next hot 100 rappers they're
essex power 100 or my personal favorite
britain's sexiest rapper that's
obviously a cap because you're bold
how could be
don't get me wrong obviously like shout
out to you you're the sexiest rapper
obviously p's got no hair in it so
that's what they say oh cool so that was
off the list yeah
hey what's going on in this part of
paper here with my way em hancho how old
do you know me where'd you know me from
how'd you know me where'd you know me do
you know me did you know me did you know
you must have knew me back then but you
don't know me now you even know us what
was the first album i ever bought
a problem you ever bought
a blueprint jay-z be
college dropout cardio west c don't stop
moving s club seven oh
why are you going to do milano
yeah i mean but like you know what i
mean you can't see
kanye west club seven left what song is
that called what's that called
believing
that's a feel good classic
oh now i don't know that one
um the answer is obviously kanye west i
reckon no blueprint juicy wow
in 2017 i was featured in which top 100
list yeah
grm's next hot 100 rappers yeah
they're essex power 100
or my personal favorite britain's
sexiest rapper that's obviously a cat
because you're bold
alchemy
don't get me wrong obviously like shout
out to you you're the sexiest rapper
obviously p's got no hair in it so
none of these are actually the answer
yeah
wow so this is the craziest curveball
yeah what does the m stand for in m
honcho
oh
over here it says hey munchies yeah
so why would butler be one cheese
munchies honcho that's gonna say that
you're obviously why are you looking at
my piggy
bee's body they're all wrong bees body
sees mystery
nah man i says mustafa
you know
where's the answer is that another thing
that's that can't find out on the next
episode of you will never know the
answer
during one of my first lockdowns what
was one of my go-to activities to pass
time oh was it a gardening b baking
banana bread which i do like banana
bread or c writing quizzes which i'll
give you a conclude me i'll never write
a quiz i'll rather suck the [ __ ] up
that was [ __ ] over a quiz over a quiz i
hate quizzes bro so i have a guardian
this is quite a bit of a quiz though
yeah isn't it i'd say obviously
gardening because that's obviously the
most it was the gardening in there yeah
okay yeah cool how to culture gardening
say nothing serious trees in the forest
i know he's an avid gardener
he's got he's got green what's they
called it green fingers he's got the
green fingers that can be from the ganja
so do you know what i made in the early
2000s i dyed my hair to look like which
celebrity justin timberlake justin
bieber
david beckham ben de la becca
or eminem the real slim shady obviously
eminem yeah
yeah
i don't even need to know the answer to
those i'm sorry i thought i was the real
slim shady in that in that music video
when all the slim shadys are there i was
standing up before you was all the
distant shading
i stood up still
so long story short guys um i know
potter way better than he knows me which
means that he's a fake friend he's a
phony he's a fugazi he's everything bad
under the sun and the moon
um
uh and yeah so um
because uh he clearly doesn't regard me
as a friend
um so yeah i'll be seeing them outside
i'm just going to be getting into one
see you guys
potter paper
don't listen to his music mustafa hancho
don't listen to his utopia out now
one more time i would
i'm going to jump for life life